You definitely have a responsibility to
your partner and your children.
Okay,
so your responsibility to your children
as far as I'm concerned,
is don't.
It's twofold.
One,
don't let your children do anything that
makes you dislike the and there's a
corollary to that,
which is don't be an idiot.
You know,
so that's partly why you need a partner
because your partner has to tell you
when your demands on your children are
excessive because you're kind of,
you know,
you're not 100 percent oriented
properly,
but still you're their target adult.
And so it's up to you to help them
choose a path that makes you want them
to be around right?
And that that's your critical
responsibility and hopefully your enough
of an,
an analog of the broader community so
that if they can figure out how to get
along with you,
it radically increases the probability
that the ability to get along with
everyone.
So for example,
if you're playing with your children two
years old,
you,
you help them,
you encourage them to play in a manner
that's fun.
And if you get that down,
then you know when you introduce them to
another child,
don't know how to play in a manner
that's fun and so great,
you've solved the problem.
The problem is to get your child to
enter into the collaborative social
world.
And so yes,
you have a primary responsibility for
that.
And then with regards to your partner,
here's something to think about with
regards to rules.
So my wife and I have had this
discussion many times and one of the
discussions as well,
how are we to treat each other in
public?
And it isn't.
Her name is Tammy.
The discussion isn't how should Jordan
treat Tammy and public?
Or how should tammy treat Jordan?
That's not the discussion.
This isn't personal.
It's how should a wife treat her
husband?
And how should a husband treat his wife?
It's impersonal and it's partly you
don't put your partner down in public.
Why?
Well,
it's not because you're hurting that
persons feelings.
That's not why.
It's that you're denigrating the
relationship that you are involuntarily.
You know,
I've some of the most painful days I've
ever spent.
One night in particular I spent with a
group of men who had been in therapy for
their marriage and who bloody well
needed it.
I can tell you that,
and they spent their whole day
complaining about their wives.
I could just made me sweat the whole
day.
I thought,
I can't believe I'm here with you guys.
I can't tell you.
Why was it just,
you know,
it was just happenstance more than
anything and I thought,
how can you be so damn dumb?
It's like it's certainly possible that
you marriage barbara married barbarian
witches fine,
but you don't have your so lacking in
sense that you would discuss that in
public,
not noticing that you pick them.
So basically all you're doing is holding
up a sign and waving it constantly that
says,
I'm an idiot.
Right?
And so well,
Dr.
Responsibility,
you have a responsibility to those whom
you love and are obligated to,
to ensure that they manifest themselves
in a manner that's most beneficial to
them over the long run.
Now you have the same responsibility.
I would say to yourself,
but you'll have blind spots.
Other people have to help you with that,
but so the rule is you know,
you don't let you,
don't you help your wife figure out how
not to make a fool of herself in public
and she extends to you the same
courtesy,
and it's partly maintenance of the
sacred nature of the relationship.
It has nothing to do with you or her.
Precisely.
It's broader and wider than that.